it's a little bit like Pascal's triangle
or it's in that kind of similar vein
where we're going to have these rows of
numbers and each row depends on what
happened in the previous in the first
row I just write one one then for the
next row every time an adjacent pair of
numbers adds up to two I'm going to
insert that in between them so I'm going
to take
a 2 and kind of put it in between those
two ones and so for the third row every
time two numbers add up to three and
they're next to each other I'll insert
that three so this will look like one
because one plus two is three I insert a
three in there I keep that two two plus
one is three so I insert a three in
there and then I keep that one so each
one it has all of the numbers from the
previous sequence we're just inserting n
for the nth row at various points so for
the next one I insert a four whenever
adjacent numbers add to four so I'll
have one insert the four before the
three and we'll kind of go through the
only other spot to insert is between
that other three so I have the two I
have the three insert a four and then
one I'll keep going for a couple more
rows just to see it between the one and
the four I'm going to have to insert a
five but also between the twos and the
threes I'm going to have to insert a
five so I'll take one five and then four
three five keep that two another five
three four insert my last five and then
a one for good measure I'll just do one
more between the one and the five that
adds up to six uh none of the next
adjacent ones seem to add up to six so
the only other one I have to add is at
the end so this Grows by a smaller
amount now someone comes along and
they're just asking questions about this
what are the patterns I can observe in
this pascal-esque pyramid and if they
just count how many elements are there
in each row they'd say this one has two
numbers in its row this one has three
numbers this one here has five numbers
seven eleven thirteen and so you're
compelled to ask okay how is this
numbers yeah and um you know I could say
is there any reason that we should
expect prime numbers from this you know
is this is just a completely random
Tower you know is there any reason we
might expect prime numbers and I could
say actually this isn't as random a
tower as you might think it's related to
these things called fairy sequences
where if I want to write out what are
all of the rational numbers where the
biggest possible denominator is one that
sits somewhere in the interval from zero
to one there's really only two rational
numbers available I can have zero which
I could write a zero over one or one
which is one over one and if I say okay
what are all the rational numbers in
that interval you know kind of the unit
interval from zero to one with a
denominator that is at most two and you
can say well I've got those those two
that I already had but now could also
include one half
into those and so you know kind of my
mark a half and what if we allow the
denominator to get as big as three and
he said well in that case I can have all
of the ones that I previously had but
also a third is available and a half and
also two-thirds is available and I'm
writing them in the order that they
would show up on the number line so I'm
kind of sorting them from least to
biggest you can show actually that this
sequence here of this Theory sequence
all of the rational numbers maximized by
a certain denominator is exactly the
same as what we were doing up here all
of the denominators on the bottom
correspond to one of the rows up here
and there's a kind of cute reason for it
or when you have a sequence of three
different rational numbers in this fairy
sequence so I'll just do one more row to
kind of see like where does one-fourth
or the fourths fit in we've got zero
over one a fourth is going to fit in
here between that and a third then we've
got a half then a third and then
three-fourths
comes up there and then one if we just
look at three adjacent elements so maybe
a
take these here note if I add up the
numerators of the two on the outside and
then if I add up the denominators also
so I add up the 2 and the four
two plus four and I make a fraction out
of those
in this case that's the same as 4 6
which is the same as two-thirds
this way of combining rational numbers
where I add the numerators and add the
denominator it has a fancy name it's
called the mediant it's kind of like
what a what someone who hasn't yet
learned about fractions might think you
do and you're supposed to add two
fractions it's not a wholly useless
operation it always gives you something
that's between those two and in fact in
these fairy sequences it'll always be
the case that the median of two that are
offset gives you the one that sits in
between you can kind of see the
connection between this and the pyramid
because you need the denominators to add
up so every time you're squishing in you
say hey I'm going to introduce the
possibility that 5 is a denominator the
only way that that could happen is if
it's two neighbors had denominators that
added up to five so you look in the
previous sequence that corresponds to
all the previous rational numbers and
you say hey when are those two
denominators going to add up to five
that's where I need to insert one but it
looks so much pure and pristine when we
have this pyramid and I don't mention
that it's related to rational numbers so
you might say oh it's kind of a natural
object and if you think hard about when
do certain rational numbers come up the
amount that you're adding has a lot to
do with the number of factors of that
for example this next time when I'm
adding one-fifth I actually know we're
going to get a lot more numbers because
five we have to add one-fifth two-fifths
three-fifths four-fifths none of those
reduce whereas when I add six it's not
that we're going to add one six two six
three six four six because 2 6 is
already accounted for 3 6 is always
accounted for so there's some you know
loose connection to the idea of how
divisible is the next number and things
like that the priminess is in there
right so we might expect so the million
dollar question yeah does this thing
keep spitting out prime numbers sadly um
the pattern actually breaks and there's
a there's a little hint to when it
breaks too um so I'll do a couple more
rows we should expect that we need to
insert numbers corresponding to 1 7 2 7
three sevenths four sevenths all of
these because none of these fractions
reduce I'm expecting so you're using
what we learned there yeah to help guide
you here now I know that I'm going to be
inserting six different sevens basically
and so this is now interesting we count
how many are there we've got oh we
should know it's going to be thirteen
plus six so on the one hand the pattern
continues
but on the other hand uh you know
there's a little [ __ ] in the armor
because 17 is sitting here just kind of
wondering why it's been left out of the
club yeah this is a this is a worried
sign it's a worrying sign but it does
actually continue the faster way to do
this rather than inserting them all like
this I can now ask you know how many
eighths are we going to be adding how
many reduced fractions are there with an
eight and the reduced fractions with
eight are basically just all the odd
numbers so there's four that I should be
adding so I kind of know that the next
one is going to get me to 23 regardless
of how many I insert in there and then
nine similar so 1 9 2 9 3 9 is not
reduced but
4 9 5 9 6 9 is reduced so I won't
include it seven ninths and eight ninths
people who are curious the the number
that we're counting here all of the
basically numerators that don't share
any divisors with a denominator would be
called the Euler tocent function of your
number nine and that's basically
counting how many numbers are there like
this numbers less than nine that don't
share any factors with it so here we
know that we would be adding six and
that gets us to 29 which again feels
pretty good
um and then in terms of 10
you know the Euler totian function of 10
saying hey how many numbers up to 10 uh
don't share any factors with it it's
actually only four you can see this with
one tenth two-tenths isn't good
three-tenths is good four tenths no good
five tenths no good six tenths no good
all of those reduce seven tenths and
nine tenths these I mean you can kind of
know this because these are the last
digits you would expect of prime numbers
all the other there's only four digits
available so if we add four to this
that's when that's when it properly
breaks it broke yeah it properly broke
properly broke um and in this case uh
you know in our previous example we
could do a little bit of analysis to say
oh well you know it was necessarily
indivisible by two three and five so
there's a good reason as far as I can
tell this is just a meaningless
coincidence
um this is a good example of uh Richard
guy's strong law of small numbers
because as we go through these first few
numbers we can have a little bit of a
sense that there's a likelihood they'd
coincide with primes because it starts
with two and then you add one to it and
then thereafter you're always adding an
even number so you're either you know
typically adding a two or a four or
maybe a six in there and so you're
getting things that are odd and so if
you think of it as a probabilistic
process you kind of guaranteed not to
hit any even numbers so that gives you a
little something and when the numbers
are so small if you're an odd number you
know it's not guarantee that you're
Prime but it's more likely it's like 50
more likely you will be so we're playing
around in this part of the number line
where the primes are still pretty dense
exactly yeah and so you're likely to see
these sorts of patterns that um just
they just don't hold that long there's
plenty of things like this actually
where I think when we do pencil and
paper intuition building it's common to
just deal with smaller numbers and you
know the thing that someone might want
to take away is understand is there a
way that small numbers are not
representative of the larger numbers and
for instance how many primes are there
between zero and one hundred it's about
25 of them that's a very atypical part
of the number line right because you go
out to any other part and uh it's many
fewer that are there it's like if you
watch Hollywood movies you would think
everyone on Earth is really good looking
exactly yeah yeah
if uh if prime numbers are like the
sexiest numbers available right that
part of the number line right towards
the beginning that is your A-list actor
group right and even if you're in your
triple digit numbers that's like your b
list actor group still not
representative and so it can be good to
form conjectures but unless there's an
actual reason I mean the vague
connection I'm like oh something primy
is happening here because we're counting
number of divisors you know you'd want
something like that to have some teeth
to it even before you attempt a proof
you sort of want to believe that the
pattern is true and that there might be
a reason for it because that informs how
you might pursue that proof and what uh
what tactics and properties you would
want to isolate presumably there are
some patterns and things that can hold
for a very very long time they're quite
dangerous yes yes there is a another
prime number related pattern that uh
takes quite a quite a bit longer to
break and you guessed it we're going to
show that to you in the third and final
video of this little Trilogy with Grant
Sanderson all the links to the videos
are down in the description along with
links to Grant's own A-list mathematics
channel three blue one Brown
and also check out a podcast we recorded
with Grant there'll be a link down in
the description plus more videos with
him and all sorts of other stuff you
might like to watch
[Music]